what has it been like already have you
had your first rehearsal and what was
that first day we've had like one day
and you know it's always like trying to
play up what's gonna work what's not
going to work and we don't know why
dad's here so we're kind of just like in
this big space don't know what to do so
I'm just making sure that you know
Tanya's moving right getting the
coordination right I'm just really
excited for everyone to see this side
yeah I don't think anyone when I say
anyone has ever seen what she's gonna
show oh boy that's what we call a tease
you know I did want to ask you though
because it could go either way you know
has America like embraced you or will
people be apprehensive dude did you
think well I guess I'm just honored to
be part of des and very humbled as well
it's been quite a year for you it has
been a lifetime but sasha is my partner
and he's gonna take me to places I've
never been
when they call you are you immediately
in with a big yes or do you have to
think about it are you kidding I would
like now you know you have a newlywed
here on your hands
right absolutely does it feel any
different let me see that ring that I
feel I feel like a man I feel mature
like every time I do
merci what was it like when you first
said hey guys it's my wife
it was it was awesome and you know what
to be funny like it doesn't feel
different
because I feel like we know each other
so well now that it just doesn't feel
different but the wedding was amazing
this is a dream come true and I've got
the best wife but it's saying that you
know that kissing more the reason that I
need to be my water yeah she says she
still wants to look around yeah so I see
that trophy environment as she puts it a
bureaucracy
I'd be like on the toilet and then she
would put it down be like how the hell
did this trying to get here oh you got a
pressure meal
[Music]